Rob here with a gamespot news update one  of Destiny's central characters ghost  has been recast prolific video game  voice actor Nolan North the voice of  nathan drake from uncharted is taking  over Peter Dinklage is out Bungie hired  north not only to play ghost in  September's taken King expansion but for  the franchise overall as such all of  Dinklage's voiceover has been white nor  three recorded everything the script  however remains the same in an interview  with Game Informer no one specifically  mentions bringing more personality to  the character I was really excited to do  this role North said you want to give  him as much personality as the world  will allow without making it  unbelievable there's a fine line to walk  there and I think we found it for more  on the taken King which launches  September 15 you go to gamespot com